a lot of demands from
support
economic support our country was
providing that
with respect to their sovereignty and
just a price calculation for fuel energy
uh the amount of uh loans
uh favorable interest rates the total
benefit for to ukraine from 91 to 1913
came to around 250 billion dollars
but it's not all at all by the end of 91
the debt of the ussr
to the foreign
countries and funds was around 100
billion
so initially the idea was that those
loans would be repaid by all the
republics of the former soviet union
solid in solidarity and pro-rata today
economic potential however russia took
upon itself the repayment of all the
soviet debt and completely repaid it
finally completed the process in
1917.
in return the newly created independent
states they should have given up
part of their foreign
soviet foreign assets and there was an
agreement in 94
signed with ukraine however kiev
didn't ratify those agreements and
afterwards it simply refused to perform
them
uh uh think uh that they had declined
claims to the diamond fund and other
assets of the former soviet union abroad
nevertheless
despite the certain issues russia always
cooperated
with ukraine openly honestly with
respect to its interests
our ties in
most different regions were developed in
19 1991
our
turnover was more than 50 billion and
the trade of ukraine with all other
european union countries in 19 until
before the coronavir virus was less than
that but we
it would
leap in ui that the
economic
the ukrainian uh authorities they had to
enjoy all the rights but not to have any
obligations
so
instead of partnership it was um uh just
begging
for money and it was just taking
unprecedented form
the first black male in the economic
fuel transit and just
uh plain uh theft of gas
they tried to use
the dialogue in kiev as uh leverage uh
for a relationship with the
with the west uh trying to obtain more
preferences
because they would say to the west that
the russian influence would grow and the
ukrainian authorities so right from the
first steps they started building it on
refuting everything the
historical
memory of the whole generation
inhabiting ukraine so it's no surprise
that the ukrainian society came about
came across a high level of nationalism
and it turned into aggressive uh
russophobia hating russians neo-nazis
but the bands like the bands a lot of
ukrainians were in the north caucasus
and um the the new demands uh were
heard often
for to take part of russia and um
through different ngos and special
services they introduced their clients
and um uh promoted them through the
government ranks and ukraine actually
never had the uh tradition of their own
uh
former state and
uh from after 91 they just mechanically
started to copy uh other structures uh
which were far away from their ukrainian
realities the political uh institutions
would
quickly be transformed uh to cater for
the needs of the new clients and gangs
which had nothing to do with the
interests of the ukrainian people the uh
civil choice european civil choice
uh of the oligarch's power was
not to create better conditions for the
people but to
[Music]
uh provide services to the opposes of
russia and to
save the billions of dollars that they
stole and hit in the western banks
some
industrial financial groups
based on radicals um the other would
promote the good relationship with
russia multiculturalism and so on and
they would come to power based on the
votes of people who supported those
ideas including millions of
southeast africa but having received the
position uh they would
make act as a traitors to their voters
but the real policy was
done by the radicals
persecuting their former uh
followers and having used uh
people law abiding citizens of modern
ideas who
used to trust to the power then like
radicals they would not show a great
aggression or would turn to illegal
actions so the radicals became brazen
their demands would grow from year to
year and it wasn't difficult for them to
impose their will to the weak
authorities who were
affected by the corruption and
nationalism virus and they would
substitute social national economic
interests of the people and the real
sovereignty
uh
of the ukraine people by speculating on
the external uh arena and the stable
state has never been formed in ukraine
and politically the elective procedures
is just a screen to divide the power and
property between different oligarch
clans
corruption which unfortunately obviously
is a an issue
to many countries including russia in
ukraine it
was formed had a special feature it just
diluted the statements
uh
all the areas or firms did and the
radicals used the justified um
unhappiness of people in 99
illegal coup d'etat to overthrow the
government according to the data the
material support of the pro testers
on the independent square from the
u.s embassy was one million dollars per
day
and
additional lunch
[Music]
amounts were transferred to the accounts
of the leaders of their position to the
tunes of tens of dollars millions of
dollars and people who really suffered
how much did they get people who died in
the altercations in the
caves and other cities quest
well you'd better not ask about that so
the radicals who grabbed the power they
instituted real terror and persecution
of people who were un uh against uh
these unconstitutional you know public
figures um that they were treated with
um denigration and the wave of
crime went through the cities of
ukrainian cities
and the the difficult uh the the most
horrible
events in odessa when the demonstrators
were burned to life in the house of
trade unions
the criminals who did that crime they
have not been punished
they've been no one even looking for
them but we know them by names and we'll
do everything
in order to punish them to find and to
bring them to court
maidan hasn't brought ukraine closer to
democracy and progress having done that
the nationalist movement
uh supported them they brought it to the
dead end
they
pushed
ukraine into this
abuse of civil war the countries split
after eight years it's going through the
shops social and economic uh
uh problems uh according to the
international organizations almost six
million people i would like to reiterate
it's around 15 percent
of
the total population not labor capable
they had to go abroad to look for a job
and quite often
as a rule
to a very low paid unqualified jobs and
there's another interesting fact
in 2020 during pandemia
pandemic
thousands of
work health workers and doctors left the
country and
from 2014 water rates uh
went by three
one third and by many times for gas to
households by ten tens of
sevenfold people just don't have the
money to pay for the gas and electric
they they just barely survive why did it
happen why is it taking place the answer
is obvious
because
everything they received from the uh
soviet union they lost everything it
stole everything they lost tens and
hundreds of thousands of
job
places that provided stable income and
taxes to the the machine tool building
uh electronic industry
vessel building aviation uh they're
either
totally
annihilated but there were times when
the whole soviet union was proud
of them they
uh
demolished the
shipbuilding yeah the nuke life which
was
built by
catherine the great and done tonight
hasn't produced a single plane huge
march who produce missiles
is on the verge of ban christie just
like
uh kremenchuk steel lloyd's and this at
least
can go on and the gas transporting
system which was created by the whole
union it has become so dilapidated that
its operation
has a lot of risk and um high administry
of course so here comes the question
poor poverty
laws of technical
industrial potential is disney european
western but democratic choice
they're fully have been fooling
people for years with that
and in actual fact it all came to the
fact that the deliberation of the
economic ukrainian criminal is just the
poor robbery of the country and the
country itself is under the foreign
external management it's not just done
by the orders from the western capitals
but
mainly even on the sport through uh
advisors ngos who are right there
and
they directly influence to for the main
uh personnel decisions all the uh powers
down to municipal to maine state
companies and corporations
including you know the gas uh railway uh
ukrainian railway postal
uh
uh ports
there are no independent uh courts in uh
in ukraine it was all given to the
representative of the international
organization who have the right to
choose the
council of
justice
and other institutions and through the
us embassy the u.s embassy directly
controls the national agency for
corruption provincial anti-corruption
bureau uh special anti-corruption
procurators office
and it's all done
through
uh good
ideas for fighting the corruption where
are the results the corruption has been
flourishing and still flourishing
even more so
and all this administrative management
methods do the ukrainians know that they
are
not even under the political or
protectorate but it's just like a colony
and
the privatization of the state uh the uh
they call themselves patriots but they
lost their national character or future
and is leading to the total
laws of sovereignty of their country
they diversify and
forcefully assimilate people the
rather in issues uh unlawful laws
uh that they've got the sort of
indigenous people who are now uh
russians who would like to
maintain their identity language they
were taught in certain terms on certain
terms that they are alien to this
country the laws on the functioning of
the ukrainian language as a
state they
take away russian from public schools
from even from from shops the
illustration uh the cleaning of the
authorities are allowed to
kick
out unfavorable
representatives and they told them tough
and that they suppress the freedom of
speech
uh they persecute the opposition
and
that the world knows of this uh
unilateral uh legal sanction against
legal entities and countries in uk
in ukraine they have
out
passed
their
curators and
they issued sanctions against mass media
physical people
and members of radha
and the
russian orthodox
church is being persecuted and it's not
an emotional evaluation
it's the specific documents and
decisions
the strategy of
a religious
split
has been turned into the instrument
political instrument then the current
government
doesn't want to abolish the
laws
that discriminate people they've
registered new bills against the clerk
clergy
and the representatives of the russian
orthodox church i would like to speak
separately about the crimea
the inhabitants of
the peninsula made their free choice
choice to be together with russia
final a clear will
and the the
ukrainian authorities can't put anything
against that will their actions is based
on
extremists even islamic extremists some
sabotage groups are being introduced
and aimed at
they still russian citizens we have
direct evidence that such aggressive
action is done with the support of the
foreign special services
in march 1921
the 2021 they introduced new military
strategy this document is totally
dedicated to the opposition
with russia
and in introducing the other countries
foreign countries into our conflict
without
the the strategy wants to form the
terrorists underground in russia and in
the crimea and it also has decided the
framework of the supposed war and the
war should support as they see it that
they can power should be strategists i
will cite them with the support of the
international community
under favorable terms to ukraine and
also as they say in kiev and i also cite
them
listen carefully with the military
support by the world community
in geopolitical
extension with the russian federation so
basically it's nothing less than
preparation to the combat action against
russia we also know that uh we know
there's been statements that ukraine
wants to create its own nuclear weapon
and it's not just a
hollow bravado ukraine still has well
the
soviet uh missiles
aviation
operational tactical uh
missile units built by the
ussr and with a range of over 100
kilometers they can increase it it just
will take time so they they have the uh
things left from the uh soviet times and
it will be much easier for them to
develop technical nuclear times and than
other countries and i'm not going to
name those countries who are developing
such weapons especially with the support
from the west
and we shouldn't exclude that
when the ukraine if ukraine has
weapons of mass destruction
to all countries and to us russia the
situation will change
drastically we cannot
uh
cannot
we should react to to that um uh danger
and the
uh western uh mentors could uh
facilitate facilitate ukraine that we
can see
how uh military pumping is being done of
the uh regime uh the usa alone from
2014 uh spent billions of dollars
equipment uh specialist training
and in the last months
uh it's
just non-stop that weapons flow uh
demonstratively
to ukraine
the uh
special services
uh and the four uh
military uh that they're headed by the
foreign uh advisers
they've always been
foreign
units from
nato the systems have been integrated so
the command chain of the armed forces of
ukraine or even separate units can be
done from the nato headquarters the usa
and that so they started to develop uh
the training territory as the military
theater
and they all anti-russian uh
[Music]
multinational uh maneuvers next year and
obviously first and foremost they're
talking about nato
uh units and they've planned uh not less
than uh 10 uh exercise like that so such
events is just
they're hiding the increase of nato in
in ukraine and the modernized upgraded
by americans um the
barista
chuggui fedex
air drums they
can take units
within very short time the open space of
ukraine is open for reconnaissance
uh
drones which are used to spy on russia
and um i would like to add that
the center of uh naval operations the
check of made this built by
um
americans uh facilitates the operation
of the nato uh vessels and use
weapons against russia and the black sea
uh russian units uh there were times
when uh
the americans wanted to create such uh
facilities in uh
the crimea but the the inheritance of
sevastopol uh and the crimeans
they uh
destroyed those plates but such a center
already operates in achaka
and in the 18th
century so the war of soldiers fought
for that uh city and due to uh their
nobility it became part of russia and uh
in that
the black sea lands were joined with
russia after the
uh
was with the osman and bayern they were
called nova rossi new russia and then
the names of the national military
leaders without his efforts uh ukraine
wouldn't have many large uh cities and
access to the black sea and in palo alto
quite recently they brought down the
monument to alexander what can you else
can you say you are giving up on your
own past on your calendar past of the
russian empire
then will follow the same rules
everywhere
i would like to say that um article 17
of the ukraine constitution doesn't
allow uh to
build military foreign military bases or
units in ukraine but this is just a mere
thing which can be easily avoided
that there are training military uh
nato uh
census and there basically are foreign
military bases they just call it a
mission and um
and they
announce the strategic course of joining
nato and then after each country has the
right to choose its own security
protection turns into military treaties
and would be basic but
according to the international
documents
security is joint and indivisible
so you can't build your security to with
the detriment to the security or for
other countries american also at the
chart of the european security
of 1999 to doctors in istanbul
and
uh declaration
so
uh
the way you build your security
shouldn't
create threats to other nations and
during the ukraine joining nato it's
direct threat to the security of russia
lecturing
the u.s
forced the decision that ukraine and
georgia will become naito members
the european allies of the usa they knew
only all too well the risk of that but
they had to
give in to the will of the senior
partner and we can just use them to uh
carry out uh clearly can't anti-russian
policy and now they are quite skeptical
uh about the ukraine appealing in night
and uh from some uh you your european
uh capitals we get a signal that said
well it will not happen tomorrow and
they make our american partners say that
okay say we not tomorrow the day after
tomorrow what does it change in the
historic perspective
and absolutely nothing even more so we
know the position and the words of the
russian leaders that the active war
action in the east of russia does not
preclude
their joining tomato if they uh
in line with the uh the requirements and
if they fight corruption
and uh time and again we are being
persuaded that uh nato is peace loving
uh defensive union no threat to russia
and now they ask us to believe the award
again but the real price of those words
we know only too well
in
1991 the issue of the
unification of germany was discussed the
uh leadership in german leadership was
promised that there will be no extension
of the
military presence not an inch in the
eastern direction and the unification of
germany will not lead to the uh uh
propagation of the
military um
uh
to to the west knights of nazareth
those who just verbal uh sounds mere
sound then we was being persuaded that
when the
countries to the east of germany if they
join that it will uh
take their historical fears it will
create more uh
friendly towards russia countries it
turns out quite the opposite some of the
eastern european um
countries
selling
their stereotypes and uh russophobic um
they
insist on increasing the uh defense
potential and it should be aimed at
russia first and foremost and it was
taking place in the 90s and the 2000s
when when russia was open and
a good will
and our relationship with the west was a
high level russia
has
performed all its obligations removed uh
troops from germany east germany and
this is eastern central
uh europe
however came the consequence of the cold
war we constantly offered
various options for cooperation in nato
in
oecd and in europe
and i will say now what i've never said
publicly this is the first time i'm
saying it
in the 2000 during the visit of the
living president of the usa bill clinton
who was leaving his position i asked him
how would america think about taking
russia into nato
i will not disclose all the details of
that conversation but the reaction
externally looked
very conservative very reserved
but what was the real uh attitude of the
americans uh to
you can see through their actions
support of the terrorists in the
northern caucasus
[Music]
about our security expansion of nato
leaving the various um security
agreements and
i i'm just tempted to ask
why what for
okay if you don't want to see us as
friends or as an ally so why do you make
an enemy out of us
the answer is only one
it's nothing to do with our political
regime or anything else
they just don't need such a huge
independence country as russia
that's the answer to all questions
that is the source of the traditional
american policy uh in russian direction
and that's where the attitude of all our
security proposals comes from you you
take just a single look at the map how
the western countries uh followed the
award not to expand just light
swindled
and we had five ways of nato expansion
99
accepted poland czech republic hungary
in 2004 bulgaria
lithuania romania slovakia slovenia
albania
croatia
montenegro north macedonia so as a
result the nato's
infrastructure
came directly to the russian borders and
that's
security crisis in in europe it affected
negatively all uh security systems we
lost a mutual uh
respect to
the situation is
degrading in romania and poland you know
when when anti-missile uh uh they are
establishing missile
areas
and it is well known that the missile
units located there can be used for
tomahawks
uh it's offensive
systems and the usa is developing the
universal standard six which together
with the uh air defense and uh
anti-missile defense can hit
water and
surface
strikes so they're expanding their air
defense system and they're getting new
offensive
capabilities according to the
information we have
the
joining of ukraine and nato
and
building the nato infrastructure is
almost done deal
it's just a matter of time
we understand clearly that under that
scenario the level of military threats
to russia will go up drastically by
several times
and it will uh increase a sudden uh blow
the american documents of strategic
planning the document of strategic
planning americans
they have
the preventive
strike against the missile complexes of
and who's the main enemy or
adversary of the united states it's
russia
the nato documents officially
we are declared the main threat of the
nato security
main citadel it will ukraine will be the
acting as a main citadel for that
if our predecessors heard about that
they would not believe there is and we
do not want to believe it nowadays
but this
ukrainian aerodromes are not from our
borders so the tactical nato aviation
including high precision weapons will
hit uh
until volgograd kazan samara astragan
level and the development of radio
location
will allow nato to control
our airspace until the euros and when we
uh the
medium and show up to range medium
nucleus
they've developed
several surfaces including ballistic
system that could heat up the the
targets uh five and a half thousand
kilometers so if such chisels are
include ukraine they will be able to hit
any target in the european uh territory
of russia and be behind the euros and
the time for tomahawk will be less than
35 minutes to hit moscow from
[Music]
haikov seven eight minutes and
hypersonic four five minutes
it's like
having a knife to your throat and they
want to implement those plants
just like they did in the last years by
expanding nato to these in expanding the
military
equipment and infrastructure
ignoring our protest warnings
our
interests they just patent uh
did whatever they like
and of course they uh want to behave
the same way
it's like when the dog
barks the carving still goes on
we
didn't agree to that and we'll never
agree to that and russia
is always
to solve the most difficult issues
through the political and diplomatic
methods uh
under the
negotiating table we understand our
global responsibilities was to be
as
back as 2007 we
put forward the initiative for the
european security the essence was so not
a single state not a single
international in the north atlantic
cannot improve their security by
through the detriment to the other
country but they kicked it out our
proposition straight away they said no
you can't
limit the activities of the nato
countries and they also said that the
legally binding
security can be
had only by the
members of nato in december last year
we
gave to the western partners the draft
agreement between the russia uh russian
uh federation do you say on the security
guarantees and the
measures for ensuring
uh
the security interests of russia and the
nato members european uh in the response
there were a lot of words but there were
some rational things but only
second-rate um
things and so they wanted just to do a
lip service and uh to put it aside and
we reacted in a certain way we said that
we are still keen on following the
negotiations but we everything will be
looked at
in its togetherness
and they have three key points first
is
no more expansion of nato
refusal of
strike systems on
the russian borders
and um to bring back the infrastructure
and potential of nato to the state of 97
when the main act
russia nato was signed so this principle
principles
have been ignored
our western partners
stated um
tried words that every country has a
free right to choose
their form of security and can join any
alliances and unions
and in their position nothing has
changed
so it's still the same reference to the
famous
policy of nato of open doors we are
being blackmailed
they are threatening us with sanctions
i think they will still
introduce those sanctions as the
sovereignty and our military force grows
and the new pretext with they will
always be found for new
or fabricated
irrespective of the situation in ukraine
the purpose is single
to
put back russia not to let it develop
and they will uh do it as before
even without any formal pretext just
because we exist
we will never give up our sovereignty
national interests and our values
i would like clearly state directly that
in the situation when
didn't get any uh answers from nato and
the threats of to our countries growing
significantly russia has
all the rights to take responsive
measures and decisions and this is how
we will act
as far as the situations of the things
in donbass
we see that the ruling uh few in kiev
keep saying about them
they do not want to uh
comply with the minsk agreement
on the contrary they are trying to
organize a blitz creek the lightning war
in the bus like it was in 2014 and 15.
you know uh how those adventures
ended
now there's not a single day without
sharing of the town towns they've
created huge
units uh heavy machinery artillery
salvo systems killing local people
blockades including people old people
children
as we say
you can't see even the end to it
but the civilized world the so-called
civilized world
the only representatives uh
uh
this
self-proclaimed western colleagues they
do not notice anything as if nothing
happens nothing exists or this nightmare
this genocide
that
for almost four million people are
subjected to only because those people
didn't agree with the uh kodata
supported by the west in 2014
and went against
the
state
movement towards nationalism
uh cave
aggressive nationalism and neo-nazism
and they are fighting for their basic
rights of people on this world to speak
their own uh
language and maintain their traditions
uh how long can it go for how long can
we stand before the
and just look at that we've done
everything to maintain the the
territorial sovereignty of ukraine we've
been fighting for the
um
2017 resolution from the september
which fixed the
minsk agreements of 2015
it didn't produce anything new
presidents come members of radha
but the radical aggressive
nationalistic
attitude of the regime that
reserved the power and russia doesn't
change
they totally
overthrown everything and
they they
went a legal way used force
threats and they do not recognize any
possibility to solve the issue of
donbass without military option so in
that connection i believe
to take the decision that has been uh
been asked to be made
for a long time to
recognize the independence of donetsk
and lugansk people's republics
i would like the federal
[Music]
union
to
support and then ratify the agreement
between
peacekeeping and support between the uh
countries and these documents will be
signed
as soon as possible
and maintains power in cave we demand
to stop the military action straight
away otherwise
all responsibility for possible
bloodshed that continues will be totally
blamed on the rules of the
regime in ukraine i state about the
decisions passed today
and i i'm sure the
national forces and the citizens of
russia will support it thank you for
your attention
the president of the russian federation
vladimir putin
and the heads of the donetsk people's
denis paschallin
signed the agreement about
cooperation and mutual assistance and
peace between the russian federation and
the nets people's republic
wow
um
guns
people's republic mr passengers signed
the government of friendship
mutual cooperation and assistance
between the russian federation and the
lugansk people's republic
so
yes
the ceremony of signing the documents
has been
completed congratulations
[Laughter]
this is the primary audio circuit for
the reuters live service
[Laughter]
this is the primary audio circuit for
the reuters live service
[Laughter]
this is the primary audio circuit for
the reuters live service
[Laughter]
this is the primary audio circuit for
the reuters live service
[Laughter]
this is the primary audio circuit for
the reuters live service
[Laughter]
this is the primary audio circuit for
the reuters live service
[Laughter]
this is the primary audio circuit for
the reuters live service
[Laughter]